folks we are leaving california and
honestly it's pretty heartbreaking
for me i grew up here i was born in
burbank california at saint joe's
i went to school at edison elementary
and i went to middle school at walter
reed
my family moved to north hollywood when
i was 11 and i've lived within like a
mile and a half radius ever since
my kids were all born here and now i am
taking off and we at the daily wire are
taking our 75 jobs
with us here are five reasons i'm taking
my family and my company
and leaving the most beautiful state in
the country number one
quality of life so when my family moved
to north hollywood it was a safe
clean suburb yes la always had a serious
litter and homeless problem but those
problems were pretty much relegated to
downtown or specific areas
of the city and then it was the task of
the city you would think to clean up
those areas instead
they decided to allow all those problems
to explode into nearly every
incorporated area of
la in 2019 there were nearly 60 000
homeless people living in la county in
2011 there were less than 40
thousand so we've increased by 50
percent in less than 10 years
these are people many of whom are
mentally ill or drug addicted
but thanks to local regulations and
legal consensus the police have been
told they are literally not allowed to
move them to dry out facilities or do
anything
with the trash that now screws every
sidewalk and underpass and overpass
and embankment in la every single one
every freeway underpass is now a tent
city
in fact they've been building
porta-potties and like hand-washing
stations
in these tent cities under the freeway
underpasses nearly every public space
has become a repository of open waste
and needles and trash
the most beautiful areas of la have
become wrecks it's one thing to pay
exorbitant taxes it's another thing to
pay exorbitant taxes to watch your city
degrade into a hell hole i mean here's
just a few stories from the last few
weeks so my wife and i decide that we're
going to take our kids down to santa
monica right one of the most beautiful
areas
in america and i'm old enough to
remember when it was a beautiful clean
area
no longer we take them down to a park my
kids are playing they
wander up a hill a little bit and my
daughter who's six comes running down to
me and she says
daddy there's a homeless man and he is
doing something to his arm what was he
doing to his arm well he had a needle
i'll let you guess
that same trip we were walking along the
boardwalk and there's just
a homeless man no shirt screaming at a
bunch of people eating at a restaurant
just screaming at them and nobody inside
doing anything
about the harassment and this is how it
is over in venice on venice beach santa
monica it's been really really bad over
there
outside my house i live in a fairly nice
area i mean i've seen a homeless person
face down
outside my home i mean it's terrible
it's terrible not for us it's terrible
for this guy how is that sympathy for
the guy he is lying face down
in the gutter and my children have seen
people peeing on walls
my kids have seen open needles last
month alone
and i'm just going to talk about what's
happened to our company our head of
social media was threatened with a
crossbow by a homeless man i mean i
don't know how that happens
across bows he a refugee from 1392
a homeless person tried to bash in the
front windows of our office
just last week we had a homeless person
going through our trash again none of
this
is lack of sympathy for the homeless
it's about having a policy that protects
tax-paying citizens their quality of
life
making sure they can be safe and make
sure that people who need care can
actually get the care they need but
california doesn't do any of that okay
two
taxes yes tax rates matter you idiots
california's top marginal income tax
rate
is now 13.3 which is already one of the
highest in the nation
the legislature is actively discussing
raising it to 16.8 percent
which on top of federal taxation means
that if you're in the top tax bracket
you're paying
54 of your income to the federal and
state government
california has historically low property
taxes because of prop 13 but the
legislature is now seeking to remove
all the prop 13 restrictions raising
them first on commercial properties and
then presumably later
on residential properties california's
legislature has been considering a
wealth tax
which taxes you based on non-liquid
assets which means
you could be paying more in tax than you
actually have in yearly income and
they want to have that wealth text trail
you for 10 years after you leave the
state this is not counting the 1
disability insurance payments of taxable
wages the statewide 7.25
sales tax the 50 cent gas tax per gallon
and a myriad of other local taxes that
drain your wallet
all for the privilege of living in a
state that can't keep the streets clean
or the parks safe
three crime crime in l.a has been
skyrocketing
well shockingly when you decide to
basically release the streets to people
who commit crime
crime has been going badly the police
have been told to back off of crime in
late july
lapd chief michael moore said the city
had seen a 14 increase
in homicide for years the state of
california has pursued catch and release
crime fighting declassifying certain
crimes as crimes devolving
responsibility to counties and cities
they called a prison realignment to
avoid culpability at the state level
basically releasing people who should be
in jail onto the streets it's been going
on for years at the local level too
in fact local law enforcement has
basically been incentivized to lie about
their own crime rates
in 2014 the lapd reported they'd
misclassified over 1
200 violent crimes as minor offenses and
then they say hey look we lowered the
crime rate
magic it was not a giant surprise when
the lapd was ordered to let the city
burn
in black lives matter riots that shut
down l.a county for a full week we were
all told to stay in our homes past 6 p.m
rodeo drive the nicest area of l.a was
forced to close at 1 pm
to allow the mostly peaceful protesters
to have their way
this garbage has real consequences down
the street i have a friend who is
building a house
beautiful house he has had in the last
month alone
the structure robbed it twice once of
copper piping
and the dumpster out front was set
completely on fire his wife has been
stalked by a homeless person back to
that person's front door just a block
further down another friend's house
has been robbed by three people he
scared them off the police came they
told him he couldn't do anything about
it because they didn't have the manpower
again i don't live in a bad area i live
in a pretty decent area
four bad policy making so the bad policy
making in california is just nuts
from regulations designed to crush
businesses the legislature has already
passed a bill
requiring publicly traded companies in
the state to staff their boards with
diversity hires so now the state's going
to dictate who's on your board to the
insanity of the education system
where kids can't learn to read i mean
literally don't know how to read but
there's how leftist propaganda
from kindergarten to the bias against
religious institutions the one-party
state here is impeded
only by occasional uncomfortable
realities there's a reason that ceo
magazine after surveying 650 ceos
named california the worst state in
america to do business
if you see our hr department you'll know
organized labor runs the government in
california that means running up insane
levels of debt on the taxpayer time
most obviously california's coveted
policy has been utterly unhinged
all of the nicest things in california
have been shut down for months without
data
to support these kinds of shutdowns so
for example disney world it's open in
florida it's been open for a few months
in florida
with precautions they've been doing it
safely no outbreaks disneyland is still
shut
they've been begging the governor to let
them open nope restaurants have opened
all over the country
with limited capacity indoor dining is
still prohibited in large swaths of the
state
schools are opening everywhere not in
l.a and if you're a private school and
you want to take precautions the state
will crack down on you
in fact our local jewish day school they
were told they could only operate as a
camp
as a summer camp if they did a summer
camp in the school it was fine
if they taught the kids then it was a
problem then suddenly it became unsafe
for coven
fifth and finally it's not getting
better there is no resurgence anywhere
on the horizon
the politics becomes more skewed every
single day this is a one-party state
right now
the state assembly is controlled by
democrats 61 to 17
okay the state government like garbage
in l.a county we have like a 17
unemployment rate the state assembly is
controlled 61 61-17
republicans have not held the majority
in the state assembly since 1996.
people who can afford to leave are
leaving in 2019 before the pandemic
before the riots out migration jumped 38
that was rising for the seventh straight
year so here's the deal
i want my kids to grow up safe i'd love
for them to grow up in a community that
actually has a future
i'd love for them to grow up knowing
their labor won't be robbed from them or
from us
that their freedoms aren't going to be
destroyed by the government that their
quality of life will be better than the
one that i grew up with that's not going
to happen in california
so we are out last rational person out
turn out the light